- [David] Hello, readers.
Today, let's talk about feelings.
Specifically, the way
the words make us feel.
That's right, I'm talking
about connotation.
The way the word feels,
the context around it.
Imagine a rock in a stream.
Well, connotation is the way
that culture flows around the word.
This is distinct from denotation,
which is more like the
dictionary definition of a word.
Companion and buddy both
have similar denotations.
They both mean friend,
but companion is a much more formal
sounding word than buddy.
Which originated as a piece
of slang from the 19th century.
So even though their denotation
or their literal definition is the same,
they feel different.
The connotation of companion is formal
while the connotation of
buddy is friendly and casual.
Good readers pay close attention
to the words the author chose to use.
They picked those words for a reason.
How do those words make you feel?
What is the author trying to imply?
How do the words propel the overall
tone or theme of the text?
So connotation is about word choice, sure.
But it's also abut setting a tone.
One way you set tone is
by expressing an opinion.
So some words may have
a similar denotation
but very different connotations.
For example, let's say I was describing
someone whose behavior was nice,
like they were behaving in a kindly way.
The way I described that person
can express how I, as a writer,
feel about that behavior.
If I trust the person,
I could describe them as sweet as sugar.
"Oh, Jake's such a sweet guy."
"Love that Jakey boy!"
But if I didn't trust that person,
like if I thought that this hypothetical
Jake's show of kindness was fake,
I could say that he was cloying or syrupy.
And those words also means sweet,
but they have a connotation of too much.
Cloying means too sweet.
So you can sort these words
in the positive and negative connotations.
Sweet is positive, cloying is negative.
Some words will have neutral
or uncertain connotations
and that's okay, too.
But it doesn't just have
to be straightforwardly
positive, negative or neutral either.
You can just use connotation for the sake
of poetic license or building a motif.
Let's say I was writing a story
about someone who started a plant nursery,
and I wanted to use words
that described growth.
But I also wanted to build in connotations
about nature or plants
throughout the piece.
And in this example I'm
a news paper reporter
and I'm doing a profile
of someone in my town,
let's call her Genevieve.
Genevieve Jenkins, proprietor
of Jenkins Orchard Supply.
She's ready for the outdoors,
she's got her big sun hat,
she's got her hoop earrings,
she's got her little name tag,
she's got a little plant necklace.
She seems like a nice person.
Okay, I could say,
"Jenkins Orchard Supply was a great
"success in its new location."
But if I wanted to put in a little bit
of that nature note, I'd say,
"Jenkins Orchard Supply
flourished in its new location."
Because flourished is
related to the word flower.
To flourish is to grow.
Grow and flourish have
a similar denotation,
but they have different connotations.
Grow can refer to plants,
but it can refer to anything
that increases in size.
A little sponge toy can grow
when you place it in the cup of water,
but it won't flourish.
Flourishing has a connotation
of flowering and success.
Continuing this idea, I could
talk about how Ms. Jenkins
decided to settle on the
location of her plant nursery.
And rather than say that she settled
into the neighborhood,
I could say instead that
she put down roots there.
Now, these are kind of extreme examples.
These nature words and expressions
are kinda getting close to jokes or puns,
but I'm trying to be extra obvious here
about the plant thing
so that you can learn
to detect more subtle
connotations in the future.
And connotation can be so personal, too.
There may be words that have important
emotional resonance for one person
that are basically
meaningless to anybody else.
When I was a kid, I
cycled through pretty much
every much team sport:
Baseball, soccer, basketball.
I wasn't good at any of them,
but I was especially
terrible at basketball
and I remember very particularly
the way that coaches would call out,
"Good hustle, David, good hustle!"
Because that was the only thing
that I could do especially well.
I couldn't dribble, I
definitely couldn't shoot.
And my passing game was not great.
So even now, I associate
the phrase, "Good hustle,"
with you're not especially
good at basketball.
Which is a shame because I'm tall now.
My experience is specific to me,
it's not universal.
It's very unlikely that you share
that same connotation
with the word hustle.
A fun game to play is
to come up with a word
and then list all the synonyms
for that word you can imagine,
and then sort them by connotation.
If you are like me, the kind of person
who enjoys sorting jelly beans by color,
you will get a similar amount
of satisfaction from that exercise.
So look out for connotations
as you read, as you write.
Words carry their dictionary meanings,
but they also carry other
cultural meanings as well.
And that's connotation.
You can learn anything, David out.